على موقعها الجغرافي وثرواتها يتنافس
الكبار روسيا الصين الولايات المتحده
واقوى الدول الاوروبيه يحاول الجميع تامين
حركاته التجاريه في العالم عبر المياه
المشاطئه للقاره السمراء لكن الجميع كذلك
يسعى الاستغلال حاجات هذه القاره لتثبيت
نفوذ عسكري طويل الامد يعزز التفوق
الجيوسياسيه لكل طرف صحيح ان الاعين
الاجنبيه التفتت قديما الى افريقيا الا ان
حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا اعادت الى الواجهه
عناوين المنافسه في العالم خصوصا المنافسه
الاوروبيه الروسيه في افريقيا
كانت فرنسا راس الحربه في الهيمنه
الاوروبيه على افريقيا سيطرت على نصف
القاره تقريبا بعد عام
1885 تقلصت هذه السيطره شيئا فشيئه منتصف
القرن الماضي امتلكت فرنسا مئه قاعده
عسكريه تقلصت الى سبع قواعد فقط وبدا هذا
الوجود يتلاشى حتى بات مهددا بالكامل رغم
ذلك تظل اوروبا حاضره في القاره في فبراير
من العام الماضي عقدت القمه السادسه بين
الاتحادين الافريقي والاوروبي اعلنت حينها
خطه استثماريه على مدى سبع سنوات لا يزال
الاتحاد الاوروبي يحظى بالحصه الكبرى من
الشراكه التجاريه مع افريقيا اكثر من ثلث
التبادل التجاري الافريقي الخارجي
عين روسيا بصيره هنا في نوفمبر 2019
استضاف الرئيس بوتين اول قمه روسيه
افريقيه الهدف تامين صفقات تجاريه ومشاريع
للطاقه وعقود عسكريه كانت روسيا اكبر مصدر
للاسلحه في المنطقه تنامت هذه الصادرات
اربعه واربعين في المئه بين 2017 و 2021
تنامى معها الوجود العسكري الروسي في
القاره في ليبيا ومالي وافريقيا الوسطى
وبوركينا فاسو اعتمدت على ميليشيا فاجنا
الذراع العسكريه غير الرسميه لموسكو
الحديث يطول كثيرا عن الوجود الامريكي
والصيني والمنافسه المحمومه بين بيجين و
واشنطن على مساحه النفوذ في القاره
السمراء هكذا يتزاحم الكبار على تثبيت
اقدام في افريقيا على المدى البعيد تتعالن
صوت الشعبيه برفض هذه المنافسه تمت من يرى
ان التواتر الاجنبي على القاره لا يخدم
الا مصالح الدول الكبرى فحسب